لليوم الرابع على التوالي تتواصل معاناه
زعيم الحزب الجمهوري كفا المقارتي من
سلسله هزائمه في جولات متعدده من التصويت
ولكن في الجلسه الثانيه عشر حقق مكارثي
تقدما كبيرا حيث فاز باكثر من 14 صوتا من
الجمهوريين المتشددين الذين عارضه سابقا
لكنه فشل في تحقيق اغلبيه الاصوات اللازمه
للمطالبه بالمنصب
يتحدثون عن صفقه في ساعات الليل متاخره
مكان في اعلن انه قدم تنازلات جديده دون
ان يتحدث عن تفاصيلها ولكنه لم يكون رئيس
المجلس ابدا اذا ما صوت خمسه من الحزب
الجمهوري
يبدو ان الاستراتيجيه الحاليه التي يتبعها
كذا المكارسي هي خوض حرب استنزاف وعلى
الرغم من تحقيقه اختراقا كبيرا في الجبهه
المعارضه له الا ان تفاصيل الصفقه لا زالت
مبهمه ربما لتجنب اثاره غضب الاعضاء
المعتدلين داخل الحزب الجمهوري الذي لا
يرفضون تقديم المزيد من التنازلات للخصوم
متعلقه بالسياسه التي يهتمون بها مثل
مساله الديون الوطنيه وعدد الاعضاء
المخولين بطلب اقصاء رئيس المجلس
من الواضح الان ان الجمهوريين المتشددين
فازوا وعلى الجمهوريين الذين دعموا مكار
في سابقا الاقرار بذلك وعليهم محاوله
المضيق قدما وفتح بوابه التغيير في ذكرى
السادس من يناير الفكره الهجوم على مبنى
الكابيتال قبل عامين تمكنت مجموعه من
تعطيل اعمالك الكونجرس واليوم تمكنت
مجموعه من 20 من الجمهوريين المحافظين من
تجميد الاعمال الرسميه لمجلس النواب لعده
ايام بانتظار ما سينتج عن هذه المعركه
التي من المتوقع ان تكون طويله ريكا
سليمان العربيه واشنطن